[Musique]
amarré sur le port de colombo le
jetliner s'apprête à vivre son grand
soin le capitaine signal y organise sa
première soirée dansante
sur le pont derniers réglages de la sono
[Musique]
ici ce sera la piste de danse
nous faisons les derniers réglages pour
ce que nous avons appelé la soirée
dédiée à l'amour le bateau porte un
message à l'attention des touristes
visiter le sri lanka
[Musique]
voilà le grand salon et le bar privé et
le restaurant vip
un décor digne de la croisière s'amuse à
un détail près il y à peine un an le
jetliner était un navire de guerre et
c'est le même capitaine signe à qui le
commande est
ici il y avait des hommes en tenue de
camouflage
armes à la main ce bateau transporter
3000 soldats vers le front on a tout
changé pour le transformer en boîte de
nuit
vous pensez que leur transportera des
trous un jour
à je n'espère pas
vraiment pas qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez
on ne veut plus la guerre
j'espère vraiment que ce bateau ne fera
plus jamais ce qu'il faisait avant
pendant dix ans le jack liner a servi la
marine au plus fort de la guerre
sur terre et en mer l'armée sri lankaise
affronter les tigres tamouls le plus
ancien mouvement indépendantiste du
monde une guérilla elle aussi équipés de
bateaux de guerre
trente ans de combat et 80 mille morts
l'armée l'a finalement emporté en avril
dernier
sur le bateau aujourd'hui la fête bat
son plein le capitaine signa est en
pleine reconversion professionnelle
comment se passe la soirée
ça va bien jusqu'ici pas de problème
et qu'est-ce qui est le plus difficile à
gérer les soldats ou ce qu'on vive
il n'y a pas tant de différences
les deux peuvent être embêtant
non en fait ce n'est pas si facile
disons que la seule différence
c'est que les soldats eux sont plus
disciplinés
un navire de guerre aux convertis en
boîte de nuit un symbole qui illustre la
renaissance du pays
nous les thrillers vivons sur une île
mais nous commençons à wana profiter de
la mer en tant que lieux de loisirs nous
en avons été privés depuis 30 ans ce
bateau est une première étape vers ce
retour à la mer
le message est clair la page de la
guerre est tournée le tourisme est la
nouvelle grande cause nationale
[Musique]
et le sri lanka a effectivement beaucoup
à offrir
pour prendre la mesure de son potentiel
touristique
nous survolons la côte
1600 kilomètres de rivages des deux
plages dont la plupart sont encore
totalement vierge
vous pouvez voir l'océan indien sur
votre gauche et souvent on aperçoit des
baleines et des dauphins
pratique fernando est en charge du
développement de l'archipel de quality
14 îles au nord de colombo sable blanc
et eau turquoise elles n'ont jamais été
exploitées à cause de leur proximité
avec la ligne de front c'est le projet
le plus ambitieux actuellement en
matière de tourisme dans le pays
l'objectif est de développer ici des
projets respectueux de l'environnement
[Musique]
et d'ici cinq ans nous allons construire
sein des chambres sur ces gilets au
minimum
pradeep fernando a l'ambition de
transformer ses terres vierges en haut
lieu du tourisme mondial
à ses côtés nous continuons le voyage au
fil de l'eau pour imaginer ce qui attend
cet archipel
pradeep à sélectionner des projets très
haut de gamme pour une clientèle
fortunée il rêve de concurrencer
l'archipel voisin les maldives
nous sommes sur l'île dit pensez vous
les travaux de construction vont bientôt
commencer c'est l'une des plus grandes
elles fait 40 hectares
il y aura un héliport des pontons tous
ces équipements qu'il faut au minimum
pour des complexe quatre étoiles
imaginez des villas les pieds dans l'eau
et bungalows sur pilotis
tout ce qu'il faut pour passer de belles
vacances sous les tropiques
quand en même temps il fait très froid
l'aménagement de cette île a été confiée
à des investisseurs indiens deux autres
à des suisses et des maldivien
les atouts du sri lanka des côtes
préserver des plages jusque là
uniquement occupés par les pêcheurs
mais plus pour longtemps
les professionnels du tourisme du monde
entier s'intéresse désormais au sri
lanka
alain clavel et feront que maintenant
font partie des pionniers qui parient
sur cette destination
il dirige une agence de voyages en
france et viennent repérer des hôtels à
inscrire dans leur catalogue
[Musique]
ça fait sombre et triste
alain et son adjoint espère dès l'an
prochain vendre 5000 séjour au sri lanka
à des touristes français chambre
standard
ils ont déjà réservé des billets d'avion
reste à trouver les logements à limbé
prospecter il ya deux ans le pays était
trop dangereuse
toutes les chambres fois même taille
aujourd'hui il est décidé à franchir le
pas non seulement à essayer
la clim
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'attendrai de voir d'autres avant de
prononcer sur ce type d'hôtel le sri
lanka est tellement à la mode que même
les hébergements de moyenne gamme sont
pris d'assaut
s'ils commencent à avoir un flot de
touristes qui arrivent ça va déclencher
une compétition en france et là il y
avoir une pénurie d'eau tél
il faut mieux trouver maintenant les
bons plans et puis c'est le garder au
chaud et après à prévoir un bon plan
selon lui c'est soit un petit hôtel de
charme soit une grande structure dans
laquelle il va pouvoir négocier des prix
de gros après dix visites ils découvrent
cet établissement
bonjour enchanté pour cela
douze pavillons à première vue rien de
formidable
ça fait béton un peu
mais à l'intérieur c'est très haut de
gamme vous avez un majordome de votre
arrivée à votre départ vingt-quatre
heures sur vingt-quatre
24 heures sur 24
c'est pas mal du tout
ce sont des duplex l étage le balcon de
la chambre donne sur une piscine privée
alain est conquis
mais pas question de le montrer de la
négociation va commencer
vous pouvez aussi réserver tout le thème
ou une année entière
oui il est 12 pavillons
je voulais loup à 3000 euros dans ce
pavillon les petits déjeuners inclus
pouvez loger 28 personnes
à peine 100 euros par personne par nuit
un rapport qualité prix intéressant
alain fait que c'est une occasion à
saisir
écoutez je veux réservé pour six mois
ça vous intéresse
on va pouvoir discuter
vous savez quand j'ai commencé à
construire l'hôtel c'est tout le monde
s'est moqué de moi en disant que ce
n'était pas le moment tellement de
problèmes dans l'ailé
mais moi j'avais confiance et j'ai
investi 4 millions d'euros nous avons
été les premiers à ouvrir après la
guerre est aujourd'hui seul de cette
catégorie
et moi je suis le premier tour
opérateurs à revenir au sri lanka vous
savez j'ai réservé 5 milliers d'avions
j'ai dit je prends j'achète
au bord de la piscine autour d'un jeu de
papa et fraîche marché c'est ce que
conclut à votre succès
à votre santé
[Musique]
à l'image de cet hôtel le sri lanka veut
s'orienter vers une offre haut de gamme
attirer une clientèle fortunée qui
contribuera au redémarrage économique de
l'île le tourisme est la nouvelle manne
du pays et chacun cherche à en profiter
l'arrivée des touristes commencent à
influer sur le mode de vie des sri
lankais le long de la côte les échappés
les bars de plage fleurissent cela ne
profite pas qu'aux étrangers les sri
lankais aussi découvre des distractions
dont la guerre les a privés dans ce pays
conservateur les femmes host enfin se
mettre à l'eau est ce la présence de ces
touristes étrangères dénudées un vent de
liberté souffle sur la côte
[Musique]
à l'âge de 60 ans non dawat i se baigne
pour la première fois
tous ces étrangers qui arrivent pour
passer des vacances ici c'est vraiment
une bonne chose pour le pays
mais ces filles là autour de vous
que pensez vous de la façon dont elles
sont habillées
je ne m'attendais pas à trouver ce genre
de nuit si c'est vrai
c'est un pays bouddhiste ici c'est très
loin de notre culture et ça pourrait
pervertir la jeunesse du pays
[Musique]
les jeunes sri lankais eux ne rêve que
de recomposer de faire tu leur et à
l'insouciance
il faut dire que le pays n'a pas que la
guerre a oublié le 26 décembre 2004 le
tsunami la frapper cruellement tuant
trente mille personnes
monique de silva est une rescapée de la
vague elle a survécu mais a perdu
beaucoup cette france est originaire de
haute savoie a fait construire un hôtel
en 2004 le lendemain de son inauguration
il est dévasté par le tsunami monique
n'a jamais eu les moyens de reconstruire
la guerre à dissuader tous les clients
cinq ans après le terrain est toujours
en friche
l'entrée principale et crée ici alors
l'eau s'est engouffrée de tous les côtés
dont le niveau d'eau se situer à ce
niveau et dans les chambres il ya eu à
peu pratique man 2 m 2 mètres d'eau un
seul bâtiment résisté cette grande
maison dans laquelle elle a pu aménager
six nouvelles chambres
un havre de paix qui mêle influences
cologna les éléments bouddhistes et où
enfin les touristes reviennent monique
conserve ses registres de clientèle il
reflète les aléas du pays l'annulation
on peut voir septembre 2009 octobre 2009
novembre décembre
céline regardé le planning c'est
complètement vide et depuis que la
guerre est finie fin fin mais voilà
c'est le redémarrage 2010 avec beaucoup
de plaisir de voir ce calendrier se
remplir à nouveau et j'espère un jour on
puisse dire c'est plein on refuse
les six chambres sont occupées par des
touristes européens
aujourd'hui ils partent à la découverte
de la côte
embarquement sur la lagune loin des
sentiers touristiques traditionnels une
soixantaine deal sauvage à la confluence
de l'océan indien et du rivière
[Musique]
et c'est tout les petites pirogues c'est
vraiment les pêcheurs en fait
leur guide sri lankais shanaka et le
mari de monique
les sages
après une carrière de cuisinier à genève
il est revenu vivre au sri lanka et
s'attellent désormais à faire découvrir
son pays natal un paysage des mangroves
authentique c'est la récompense pour ces
touristes belges
mais quand j'ai entendu qu'elle est la
guerre était terminée comme c'était une
destination que j'avais en tête depuis
longtemps
avoir un pays qui avait sûrement envie
de
ces mêmes qui vaut mieux venir tôt
vous êtes en raid et cela pour vous et
ça je pense
après des années pendant lesquelles les
touristes lui ont manqué shanaka
découvre aujourd'hui qu'il n'est plus
seul sur sa lagune
réserve donc
je pense qu'il faut vraiment respecté il
faut un grand respect pour la nature
parce qu'il faut aussi respecter les
pêcheurs l'ami local
et l'info pas trop non plus surtout là
en fait surtout ici
non pas trop ici voilà
réservé aux pêcheurs tout le temps et on
voit pas de bain de soleil c'est vide et
j'espère que ça va rester comme ça oui
mais là c'est notre sourire les gens du
village c'est du joli comme ça on vient
d'avoir les hôtels bétonner les plages
bétonnée
on aimerait que ça continue
une partie du sri lanka reste pour
l'heure à l'abri des promoteurs
la presqu'île de jaffelin
le ministère français des affaires
étrangères l'a classé rouge
comme tout le nord est du pays il
conseille de ne pas se rendre dans cette
zone où l'armée sri lankaise a combattu
les tigres tamouls
après une heure d'avion nous voici aux
abords jaffna ancien fief de la guérilla
nous avons obtenu un permis spécial
auprès du ministère de la défense grâce
à marie caroline willaume elle est
chargée de la promotion du sri lanka à
paris il y a quatre ans elle travaillait
pour une organisation humanitaire dans
cette région elle y revient pour la
première fois
pas vraiment changé
en 2006 au plus fort de la guerre elle
avait quitté le pays pour des raisons de
sécurité elle revient aujourd'hui pour
évaluer si jaffa est de nouveau
fréquentable par des étrangers
passées les maisons en ruines elle
découvre un centre ville qui renaît
sur le bord de la route en fait c'était
pas annexe
la galère commence vous disparaître dès
ses premiers pas en ville elle tombe sur
un ancien confrère salut comment ça va
bien tu es là jusqu'à quand mercredi
tout est très calme maintenant il n'y a
plus de check point et vous pouvez aller
n'importe où alors qu'avant il y avait
beaucoup de restrictions
maintenant tout est plus facile
tu va même pouvoir aller à la plage
le sourire retrouvé c'est le message que
veulent faire passer les autorités sri
lankaises
le couvre feu a été levé il ya deux mois
la ville sort de 30 ans d'isolement
des sri lankais re découvre la
possibilité de sortir sans crainte d'un
attentat une ambiance bien différente de
celle qu'a connue marie-caroline
lorsqu'elle vivait ici
j'ai l'impression que ce qui reste de la
période difficile c'est certainement les
traces physiques les impacts
de balles sur les bâtiments des choses
qu'on peut voir qui témoignent du passé
de jaffna mais par contre j'ai
l'impression que dans les mentalités il
ya vraiment quelque chose de de très
beaux visite que les gens ne veulent pas
sonné vers le passé mais plutôt vers le
vers l'avenir
[Musique]
leurs activités et certainement le
tourisme aura une grande part l'attend
merci avoir enchanté
[Musique]
la principale curiosité de la péninsule
de jaffna est un temple isolé sur une
île on y accède en traversant un lagon
ses visiteurs viennent tous du sud du
pays ils sont membres de l'ethnie
cinghalaise il revient en territoire
tamoul pour la première fois depuis
trente ans
les femmes crime mais ce n'est plus par
crainte de la guérir
ses propos ici c'est la première fois
qu'on va sur l'eau on demande à dieu de
nous protéger
nous implorons sa protection
[Musique]
enfin la terre ferme
les tamouls considère ce temple commun
de leurs lieux saints pendant le conflit
il était inaccessible coincés dans la
zone de guerre
aujourd'hui les deux communautés du pays
cinghalais tamouls
redécouvre ce du sacré
[Musique]
la visite terminée le groupe de
touristes pique nique insouciant les
pédales c'est un plat typique difficile
de jouer
il se déplace très librement
on est venu sans crainte c'est très bien
visible
comment vous voyez l'avenir il faut que
ça reste comme ça
après trois jours de repérage à flat
marie-caroline croit dur comme fer à
l'avenir touristique de la région
fait cueillir
un conflit pendant une trentaine
d'années ça fait aussi qu'on pénètre
dans un territoire où le temps s'est un
peu arrêté c'est peut-être justement
parce qu'il n'ya pas de touristes
étrangers que cet endroit est assez
attirant parce que justement on se sent
pas vraiment comme un touriste mais
plutôt comme un voyage eux
nous terminons notre voyage par une
rencontre inattendue
uniformes impeccables jeux dans l'eau
pour la première fois de leur vie des
filles est issue des communautés
cinghalaise est un maul se rencontrent
c'est la première fois que vous voyez
des tamouls ans oui c'est super
elles sont vraiment très gentilles
c'est un programme de l'onu pour
resserrer les liens entre les
communautés
ils vont nous montrer ensemble dans le
monde entier tu te rends compte
[Musique]
elles nous ont appris quelques mots de
tamouls nous on leur a enseigné un peu
de st gall et on rajoute de l'anglais le
langage des signes et comme ça on arrive
à se comprendre
elle est comme ma soeur une super copine
plus qu'un terrain d'aventuré
touristique la mer devient le lieu de la
réconciliation
celle d'enfants de la guerre qu'ils ont
aucun mal à faire la paix